Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you are going to see glimpses of the future
many of which come from the amazing AI research
papers that appeared not so long ago. First,
NVIDIA just showcased their new system which
can automatically come up with dialogue for
a virtual character in a video game. First,
the text what the character needs to say will be
synthesized by an AI, then a text to voice AI will
make it actually say it in a human voice, and the
mouth movements will also be synthesized. Look.
It sounds a little stiff, could be a bit
more natural, but this is only the first
version of something that was previously nearly
impossible. And now, here it is, and it may be
part of the video games and perhaps even the
virtual assistants of the future. This can be
combined with Unreal Engine 5 and Metahuman, which
is an amazing system for creating virtual humans.
And, look at this. What is this? This is
NVIDIA’s Neuralangelo, this performs something
that researchers call photogrammetric neural
surface reconstruction. What does that mean? It
means that you can scan your environment with your
phone camera, and out comes a 3D mesh that you can
use to create a virtual world for video games, or
have a videoconference that actually takes place
in this environment. Not just a 2D image, but
actually being there. Previous techniques really
struggled with this. Look, here is an input scene
with a screw clamp. This is the Neural Implicit
Surfaces paper from two years ago, and as you
see, it was unable to reconstruct the details
on the screw. A more recent technique, NeuralWarp
from just one year ago provides smoother results,
that much is clear, however the high-frequency
details are unfortunately still lost. Now,
with Neuralangelo, look. Wow. Now that is what
I call a high-quality reconstruction. Screws
finally looks like screws! And the paper reveals
that this particular scene was not just a fluke,
the new technique is so much better than the
previous ones on a number of different scenes. So,
high-fidelity neural reconstruction is
becoming more and more of a possibility today.
Loving it. We will be able to create
a digital version of any place on this
planet and play with our friends there.
How cool is that? What a time to be alive!
Okay, so generating speech is a possibility, and
creating amazing virtual spaces is a possibility
too. However, what about animation? Here is
an amazingly fun paper that I would love to
show to you. And it is about simulating locomotion
for virtual gibbons. This is an AI-based method
which can jump from vine to vine. Wait a second,
this can’t do anything. Well, yes, but this is
just the initial part of the training. It doesn’t
quite know how to do this yet. Note that to the
best of my knowledge, some of this is footage
that is exclusive to us, so you can only see it
here on Two Minute Papers. Nowhere else. But this
doesn’t seem to work too well, does it. However,
this is a SIGGRAPH paper, so you Fellow Scholars
immediately know that this has to be real good.
So, you know what? Let’s wait an hour for it
to learn. Now, an hour later. My goodness,
look at that! It can now jump from vine to vine,
and hold on to your papers, because it gets even
better. Look. It now understands that if it gets
a couple more swings before jumping, it can even
do this. Wow. That is incredible. Make sure to
have a look at the paper in the video description,
it is a ton of fun. And I would like to send a
huge thank you to the scientists at the University
of British Columbia for also publishing the source
code of this project for all of us for free.
So, as you see, AI research is progressing
so incredibly fast I may have to showcase
these works not one, but three per video to
be able to keep up. What do you think? Did
you enjoy this? Let me know in the comments
below. So for now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!